وبمناسبه حديثنا عن فعاليات السعوديه
فعطله نهايه الاسبوع كانت حافله
بالفعاليات لكن حفلتين سيطرتا على
العناوين واصداؤها ملات المنصات اكثر من
غيرها نبدا من نهار الجمعه مع الفنانه
انغام التي احيت حفلا على مسرح ابو بكر
سالم في الرياض بعنوان ليله صوت مصر انغام
غنت على مدار اكثر من اربع ساعات اجمل ما
غنت في تاريخها وكان معها على المسرح
والكسره كامله بقياده المايسترو هاني
فرحات
البعيد الهادي
[موسيقى]
وفي نفس المكان في
انا
مستنيه اجمل حبيب في عينيا مش ده اللي
بتقوله علي انا
[موسيقى]
من غيرك او بيك وش
و
[موسيقى]
مو على
الفنانه انغام كان في الكثير من المفاجات
ايضا فالى جانب الحضور الكبير من مشاهير
حضروا الحفل لدعمها والاحتفال فيها شاركها
على المسرح نجوم كانوا مفاجاه للجمهور
وصعدوا بعض الاغاني معها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شيء
[موسيقى]
بفكر فيك كتير بالي عليك مشغول
وانا بكتبلك كلام ومش
مبسوط واحلف بتحطي مش مشهور
[موسيقى]
ولا انساك عشان ارتاح
وعمال قلبي
بيدك وحتى الصبر مش نافع انا مش عارفه
اعمل ايه
ويوم
جراحي تزيد
ويكبر شوقي جوالك ما ترحمني بقت فايق تعبت
خلاص من اللي انا فيه
[موسيقى]
حفله وانغام كانت الجمعه اما السبت فاحيا
فنان العرب محمد عبده احيا امس سهره
استثنائيه مليئه بالطرب الاصيل ضمن جلسات
ليالي الرياض وبالطبع وكمل معتاد اسم
الفنان العرب و هاشتاج باسم الحفل تفضلوا
المنصات ومحركات البحث ومقاطع الحفل كانت
الاكثر مشاهده نحن وصلنا لنهايه الحلقه
ساترككم مع مقاطع منحف فنان العرب الى
اللقاء
وانا بلغنا فيه غايته
[موسيقى]
والصبر انا تجرعنا
امرا اخطيت في حقي
[موسيقى]
والعفو عند القدره
اراك عصيا
[موسيقى]
شيمتك الصبر
عليك
ولا امر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يا ولد
عذاب الحب البحر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جميل وحبيبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وتصبح على
[موسيقى]